das was ein forschungsteam aus den usa
da gemessen hat ist wohl das seltenste
bislang je beobachtete ereignis im
universum
konkret geht es um den radioaktiven
zerfall des isotops xenon 124 der
bislang nur theoretisch vorhergesagt
wurde und damit könnte diese entdeckung
und beim aufspüren der mysteriösen
dunklen materie helfen klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen der unterirdische
xenon 1t detector in italien machte
diese rekordverdächtige entdeckungen
möglich eigentlich suchen
forschungsteams hier nach möglichen
teilchen der dunklen materie den
sogenannten wiki interacting massive
particles wird also auf deutsch ein
schwach inter agierendes massives
teilchen diese teilchen werden da
gesucht es ist eine vermutung für die
zusammensetzung der dunkle materie 1,4
tonnen hochreines flüssiges xenon sind
in den gigantischen abgeschirmten tanks
abgefüllt doch dass man dieses xenon zum
leuchten bringen kann das ist äußerst
selten sehr sehr selten sogar anders als
bei halogenlampen oder scheinwerfern die
man zu hause hat und bei denen es nichts
besonderes ist diese leuchten zu lassen
doch zurück zum experiment denn hier
wurde tatsächlich der radioaktive
zerfall des isotops xenon 124 beobachtet
und das ist eine echte premiere denn
dieser zerfall wurde bisher zwar
theoretisch vorhergesagt konnte aber
bisher noch nie registriert werden und
das ist kein wunder denn die sogenannte
halbwertszeit von 10 924 liegt bei
achtung 18 trilliarden jahren zur
erinnerung eine trilliarde bedeutet eine
eins mit sage und schreibe 21 0
dass es wirklich unsagbar viel zum
vergleich unser universum ist dagegen
nur schlappe 14 milliarden jahre alt der
grund dafür dass der zerfall von 10 924
so selten ist liegt an einer
konstellation die sich einfach fast nie
ergibt in der fachsprache ist von einer
so genannten double electron capture die
rede diese konnte insgesamt erst bei
drei elementen überhaupt beobachtet
werden im detail nehmen dabei 2
protonen im kern des atoms gleichzeitig
zwei elektronen auf doch nicht nur dass
dieser doppelte anfang von elektronen
gelingt nur wenn sich diese zur
richtigen zeit auch noch extrem nah am
atomkern befinden
dazu der new yorker wissenschaftler ist
im braun damit haben wir quasi ein
seltenes ereignis mit einem zweiten
seltenen ereignis multipliziert was das
ganze ultra markt dabei ging es dem
forschungsteam ursprünglich gar nicht
darum diese sehr seltene einzelereignis
zu provozieren vielmehr waren die
experten und expertinnen wie gesagt auf
der intensiven suche nach dunkler
materie und nach seltenen zusammenstößen
doch auch dafür hatten sie eine große
menge an xenon das übrigens auch nur zu
etwa 0,1 prozent aus diesem sehr
seltenen isotope steht zusammengebracht
vergleichbar mit dem lotto spiel bei dem
man seine chancen zu gewinnen erhöht
wenn man eben viele lottoscheine
ausfüllen damit ein einzelnes teilchen
zerfällt muss das material zudem
störungs arm und sehr sauber gelagert
seien
so wie eben in der tiefe von 1,5
kilometern wo der sehr sensible xenon
110 direktor arbeitet und dann war es
plötzlich so weit die fachleute stießen
bei der analyse der daten vom februar
2017 bis februar 2018 auf lichtblitze
die nicht von einer teilchen passage
herrühren könnten
der energiegehalt dieser strahlung
passte zu keiner bekannten hintergrund
quelle sondern musste wohl aus der hülle
des xenon atome stammen detaillierte
untersuchung bestätigte diese vermutung
bei dem kollaps in der atom- hülle
werden elektronen aus der innersten
schale der atom hülle entfernt und die
dadurch entstehenden lücken mit
elektronen aufgefüllt die weiter außen
kreisen
durch dieses nachrücken geben die
elektronen energie ab und zwar in form
von röntgenlicht dieses konnte durch den
detektor eingefangen werden ein großer
glücksfall und erfolg für das beteiligte
team dazu ist in braun damit sind wir
erstmals zeugen dieses vorfalls geworden
das ist der langsamste längsten prozess
jemals direkt beobachtet worden aber
nicht nur dass der erfolg verdeutlicht
wie sensibel und empfindlich der
detektor schon jetzt arbeitet und wie
viel potenzial in dieser messmethode
steckt und zwar auch für signale geben
nichts mit dunkler materie zu tun haben
die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen hoffen jetzt dass
sie mit dieser neuen erkenntnis die
struktur modelle für schwere atomkerne
überprüfen können zudem findet derzeit
ein umbau des experiments stadt und die
neue phase mit der bezeichnung zenon nt
startet hierbei werden störsignale
vermehrt unterdrückt und die aktive
detektor maß an verdreifacht
letztendlich wird dieser umbau den
sektor um eine größenordnung
empfindlicher machen ein guter schritt
in die richtige richtung um dann
vielleicht schon bald die rätsel der
dunkle materie zu lösen die chancen
stehen nicht schlecht denn flüssiges
xenon hat eine hohe dichte und jedes
einzelne atom hat viele einzelne
elementarteilchen mit denen vielleicht
irgendwann doch einmal ein stück dunkler
materie kollidiert neue rätsel um dunkle
materie anklicken anschauen und
natürlich klicks und science fiction
abonnieren falls ihr das noch nicht
gemacht haben solltet ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran